[music]
let's just say I only have Ukrainian
roots but all my life I lived in
Russia because my father,
although he was from Ukraine, but he died
immediately after my birth and I rather
if you ask about identity, I
rather feel like  a
Russian woman, and as if my whole
conscious life naturally passed on the
territory of Russia,
therefore, when the war began, of course, I
was not indifferent to what was happening,
because, at that moment, it was
really a point of no return,
millions of refugees were pouring blood around, I
saw all this on my screens  but
nevertheless, we showed on Channel One
such a looking-glass, we constantly created a parallel reality.
Why do
you have to understand that in two you
can say that
the war became such a point of no return
when it was no longer possible to remain silent because
I just for these 10 years you can
say that I was hiding my head  into the sand and
tried to
protect myself from the reality
that we have because I
understood very well that Russia is becoming
more and more a totalitarian
state that Putin
has destroyed all independent media in these 20+ years
that he has destroyed free elections
that he has destroyed free  courts and all
that Russia is sliding further and further
into this reality but I
felt like a fine grain of sand
that cannot protest against
this Because I did not see
a way for myself where to go Could the
head of your channel go to
Buckingham Palace and receive instructions
from the Prime Minister  minister sunako I think
not. And all the heads of all Russian TV channels of the
First Channel NTV Second Channel
they go to the Kremlin every week and
receive the so-called training manuals, these are not
some kind of books or leaflets, it’s
just such a flyer and they are explained in words
what we are showing How
in words, we call some other
specific phenomenon to the
top management and the middle top management is
already lowering these instructions to the lowest
level and no one discusses these orders
all TV channels in Russia work as
information troops this information
troops give them an order they do it and
do not ask  there can be no questions, no
creativity on Russian television,
you can only
practice in the words that you will
call the Ukrainian regime there, the junta, or
drug addicts, or whatever, but as far
as Putin is concerned, it is clearly
defined that no negative information is
used next to the name of Putin and
we  constantly for many years
sculpted from Putin the tsar of the Russian land
Putin was always good and there were always
bad boyars the servants of the tsar who
did something wrong and he
books
there was no war Russians against war
and it was written that do not believe This
propaganda is lying to you here  and as
Russian political scientists said, first of
all, a strong signal was sent to the
Russian elites, first of all, even to
non-Russians, then watch this is
Putin’s favorite program, this is
Putin’s favorite presenter, they say that he watches
this program almost every evening,
they themselves produce this Propaganda
called cream  or they consume it themselves And that is
why it was, first of all, such a
strong signal to the Russian elites
look that even here in your heart of
propaganda people think differently and I
can say that about 80 percent of
my colleagues they think about the same
as me they have liberal views  but let’s
say they are hostages of this system They
understand perfectly well that they have nowhere to go
that as soon as they start protesting
their life will be immediately destroyed
I felt that I did everything right
but I didn’t expect at that moment what the
consequences would be at that moment it
seemed to me that they  they will put me in jail right away,
I was ready to go to jail for 2 or 3 years
for these actions, but events developed.
So with me. We went along this path, my
favorite path, they let me in with a
minimal fine, and then
this whole game of conspiracy manipulation began, the
Kremlin’s favorite action and I felt  myself
inside the information war because at the
beginning I was publicly called a traitor to the
Motherland and a person who went to the
British Embassy and almost a
British spy, then after a
while when I left Russia
to work in Germany And then
rumors began to spread that I was working for
some Russian special services and I
constantly felt myself inside this
information war and it was all
very difficult from an emotional point of view
because I was between two
fires
[music]
at that moment I probably wasn’t very
worried about it but I never
imagined  that it will go down this
path immediately after my live protest
against me, my ex-husband began to play against me.
He is one of the stop leaders of
Russia Today, he works with
Margarita Simonyan and I never
expected such a path. Well, how would we be on
good terms after a divorce  I
never expected that he would start playing
against me and start harming our
children because immediately after my
protest he sued me and
tried to take away my parental rights
and in the end he managed to
restrict my parental rights and
by decision of the Russian court  the children should
live with him, but because the mother is involved in
political activities, such was the
verdict of the court, so I did not expect
the betrayal of my loved ones, let's just say
that they would start this particular game
against me, so
it was a very dramatic story,
because I returned to Russia
continued to protest against the war
Two more times I was fined for
discrediting the army, then for the third time
they already filed criminal charges against me.
that moment and the
Russian court constantly said that the
dead children are fakes, they put
me under house arrest and my ex-
husband accordingly took away my
daughter and said that you will never see your mother again,
she is a criminal and will soon
go to prison. That's literally for
my lawyer  constantly told you to
run away I already spent two months under house
arrest he said you need to run to
save your life but I said I would
never book from Russia without my daughter
because I would never see her later
for many years
but my daughter was accordingly locked up by
decision of the basman  court in his house And the
daughter, by decision of her father, was locked in his
apartment and
we tried to connect But it all didn’t
work out because he was reliably
guarding her and in the end she was able to
run away from him to me and then we already
began to plan this Escape and
literally  there, after a few days,
they ran away
[music]
and when she had already come running to me,
we began to plan this Escape, we
didn’t know where to run until the very end,
because the lawyer said that Yes, there are ways
to leave Russia, but the people who
organize it, they only do it or
should be  some strong man
who can walk 20 kilometers
through the swamps No one wanted to take on
such an escape woman with a child
and it was almost impossible
to do but in the end my lawyer
found a way that more or less
could run me to the last  I didn’t
know at all how it would happen
because I was sitting without the Internet without a
phone without anything and
just a car drove up to our house We
sat down the lawyer said without asking any
questions and I knew in which direction
we were moving But
I didn’t know how it would be organized  in the end,
we changed 7 cars and
naturally everything didn’t go according to plan because the
last car got stuck in the mud
literally there, probably a few
kilometers from the border, but we didn’t
know this, we jumped out into a bare field, we
had escorts who helped us
cross the border, but we were in  at some
point, we got lost there, and the
cellular connection and we wandered around the field,
which was an unusual field, it was a
plowed field with huge clods of
earth, it was almost impossible to walk along it,
and all this was at the limit of
human capabilities at some
point, I just
fell to the ground and said that it’s
better to put me in jail
because it’s impossible to go any further and my daughter
said that let’s get up because
you have to go otherwise they will put you in
jail and
we have to get out of here everything is here moms
and sanki
[music]
you understand  this war has divided millions of
families in russia my family is exactly
the same as other families in russia
because the
older generation is usually in favor of
war the
younger generation is more
western oriented
so
russian society is very frustrated e.g.
since I
opposed Putin,
she considered me a real criminal
and that’s all. Of course, it’s very difficult. As
for my son, he chose towards his
father. He decided to stay with him.
were faced with a
very difficult choice Because they
had to decide You are either for the war with dad or
against the war You are with mom and this is a very
difficult choice and
I would not want to be in the place of my
children
I hope that some more time will pass
and mine  son When Russia loses this
war When
Putin's personality cult is debunked I think that he
will understand everything
you know at this moment I usually when
they ask me for safety I start
joking Putin will not have enough rookie for
all the dissidents because after the start of the
war so many people began to talk
words against this war and against the
criminal military regime by Putin.
I think that Evan was taken. Most likely,
he will be held hostage by token coins and
Putin will probably want to cancel it on
some other
Russian
loyal regime people who
are now either in American or
British prisons. But this is in  first of
all, the arrest of Evan This was a
powerful signal sent to all foreign
journalists that Russia has now
turned into a country where it is very dangerous
to be a foreign journalist and
this is a very powerful signal
[music]
Navalny hero Navalny hero he
returned to Russia, he is with his people, but it
was immediately clear that he  will not get out of
prison as long as Putin remains in
power now he is being tortured being tortured right in
front of the whole world
if God forbid something happens to
Navalny
must understand
that Russian society is so
intimidated now that it will not go on the
street probably
in any case because the police
structures are everywhere the police are everywhere as soon as
you just raise your head right away your
life will be destroyed I have more
like more hopes for Ukraine as soon as
Ukraine starts to win  this war, as
soon as there is a successful counteroffensive, the
split of the Elites around Putin will begin, and this is,
first of all, what can destroy
his regime, because Look now
Yevgeny Prigozhin begins to actively
speak against the Ministry of Defense
Kadyrov begins to say some
other things and these groups start
among themselves  to fight, they begin to
fight for power, these are already good
symptoms,
symptoms of the fact that
in Russia everything has not been going according to plan for a long time
And that this system is starting to fall apart
from the inside, what is it
I really hope that Russia will not follow the
path of the Civil War, but there are
already all the prerequisites for this  these structures
that have formed around Putin
have risen in the war Prigozhin’s
Kadyrov’s they will begin to quarrel and
fight for power and of course it will be
very difficult times for Russia,
Russia is already practically on the verge of
collapse, as I’m not bitter about it,
but the struggle for power will be very
tough  and
how this will happen is hard to say,
perhaps some
national patriot will come to power in
Russia, it will be even more difficult and
tough times, but then it should be
some kind of transitional stage, and I still
think that Russia will return to the path of
democracy because  that Russians have
been living under democracy for a very long time, they are
used to, they have traveled a lot, they have
seen this world, they have already
understood all the benefits that the
civilized world brings, and now it is very difficult to
isolate Russian society again, as it was in the Soviet
years, and again place it in a different way.
now
they are very frightened And so Drones in
the Kremlin, she
discredited the Russian army, the
Russian air defense system in much the same way
as the landing of Mathias Rust on Red
Square in 1987
It is already clear that this regime has already begun to
fall apart and security measures
during the parade were taken unprecedented
because for the first time  federal channels did not
even show the rehearsal of the parade and the
parade itself was very short in time, there
was very little equipment on it and
this regime is very very scared now at
the moment it is afraid and it has come to the point
that even in Russia in many
cities parades have been canceled and canceled everywhere  The
immortal regiment,
of course, is not a protest from below, now it is
impossible because the power structures
are everywhere almost 3 million people
serve
the FSB police other structures, this is not
counting all sorts of private security there.
Therefore, I would not now hope for
a protest from below, because it is practically
in the history of Russia that Stalin's times have come
everyone is afraid they are afraid to even
participate, it has come to the point that they are
even afraid to participate in questions on the street
if you say something against the war,
even if you say something there, they will
definitely initiate an administrative case against you.
for drawings of
military children, and therefore I would not now
hope for some kind of protest from below,
because there is not even a leader who
is able to organize this Navalny in
prison, the rest of the leaders are
abroad on the territory of Russia, there is not
a single active opposition force left
that could at
least consolidate  this protest Therefore, in this case,
we can only talk about the split of the Elites. And the
conspiracy does not mean that it will be
some kind of conspiracy there with the murder and
poisoning of the dictator, maybe someone
will come to Putin and tell him
Volodya will hint the war is lost you are already tired
leave  let's need to change something, otherwise the
people will just tear us apart what they were hiding.
Well, I already said that a conspiracy of
the elite is possible, but it is probably impossible to stop it,
he understands perfectly well. As
soon as he loses this war, this will be
his last day and he is very afraid, he
fears for his life  we see that he is
hiding from everyone and sitting in a bunker he
appreciates his life
Now at the moment I cannot
return to Russia because I am on the
international wanted list and a
warrant for my arrest has already been issued for me, as for me they will
immediately put me in jail for 10 years  in prison, as
for the future, if Putin dies or
he will be judged by
such people who were subjected to
repression under anti-war articles,
all charges will be dropped.  the
last to fight for a better future
for their country, because there are a
lot of people in Russia who
oppose Putin and this war is
primarily Putin and his entourage.
the beginning of the
war and they all help Ukraine to the best of their ability they
send money to Ukraine they send
some kind of humanitarian aid they
help to
take children out of there from the territory of
Russia a lot of such help comes, as it were,
and therefore I think that
from this war from the Victory of Ukraine in  this
war depends on the future of Russia and the entire
civilized world